be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
so without wasting too much time we're
just going to jump straight into this
list so the first infinity gym on our
list is the Seoul gym now the soul gym
was first introduced into Marvel Comics
with warlock issue number one and the
Seoul Geum actually has the power to
steal the souls and manipulate the souls
of others one of the other cool things
about the soul gym is that it's actually
a gateway to another world called soul
world now we're not explicitly told
whether or not the occupants in soul
world are people who have had their
souls trapped by the soul gym or if
there were people who would have their
souls trapped because they failed to
wield the soul gem correctly but because
the power of the soul gym is basically
the power to strip other people of their
souls it would stand to reason that they
most likely have their souls confined
here because somebody else put them
there regardless all souls that reside
in the soul world are benign and the
world itself is basically a peaceful and
a tranquil world now the next gym on our
list is the reality gym which allows us
wheeler to manipulate reality now the
reality gym in my opinion is the most
powerful and the most dangerous of all
the gyms and the reason why I say that
is because a status explained in the
Thanos quest where he was tracking down
the gyms to form the Infinity Gauntlet
the reality gym requires an
extraordinary mind to harness its power
without actually going insane and that
was proved this when he had used the
reality gym and demonstrated his power
to the collector who had previously been
in possession of it and almost drove the
collector to madness by virtue of the
warping of reality that took place
around him now coming in at the number 3
spot on our list is the mind gym now the
mind gem is actually pretty
straightforward here the mind gym allows
this user to tap into the subconscious
of the universe which basically means
that they can read every mind in the
universe simultaneously but it can also
bend those minds to their will in
addition it has the ability to grant its
wielder unlimited levels of telekinesis
and telepathy and to actually move the
mind of its wielder to its absolute peak
now coming in at the number 4 spot on
our list is the space gym now the space
gym allows us wielder to move anywhere
instantaneously through space and to
manipulate the very fabric of space
itself and also exist everywhere at one
time now in the Thanos quest again when
that'll just trying to track down the
gyms he found that the space gym was in
possession of a person called the runner
and the runner is one of the elders of
the universe and what Thanos had learned
here is that where the runner believed
that he was moving extremely fast that
in fact the space Jim was reading the
subconscious mind of the runner and so
the space Jim knew with a runner wanted
to be before the runner actually
realized where it was that he wanted to
be and so for the runner he was actually
teleporting rather than moving extremely
fast coming up next is the time Jim now
much like the mind Jim the time Jim is
actually pretty straightforward here the
time Jim allows its wielder to
manipulate all facets of time by
freezing time traveling into the past
traveling into the future and even
creating unending loops of time now
during the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
when Thanos had managed to assemble the
entire affinity gauntlet after
assembling all the Infinity Jim's Fire
Lord and Drax a destroyer were actually
sent back to the prehistoric age of the
planet Earth during the conflict and
were to move them away and out of the
path of Thanos now the final Jim on our
list is the power Jim now the reason why
I had kept the power Jim for last is
because the power Jim is actually the
foundation for all the other gems that
have been listed above the power Jim
draws on all the power that has ever or
will ever exist in the Marvel Universe
and because of that it's able to
basically act as a battery to move all
the other gems to their full potential
without the power Jim working in unison
with any of the other gems the gems will
not work to their maximum capacity and
so once the analyst was able to acquire
the power Jim followed by all the other
gems and then assemble them
Thanos had gone on to launch what was in
effect the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
which is of course a video that you can
see here on my channel by clicking the
annotation at the end of this video now
with all that being said as it stands
right now this moment in Marvel Comics
the infinity gems don't exist anymore
they've been destroyed
when the incursians initially happened
and various alternate realities began
crashing into one another when an
incursion popped up in the earth-616
reality Captain America and the
Illuminati had banded together and tried
to use the Infinity Gauntlet to push
that earth away and the result was that
all of the gems except for the time Jim
shatter they simply just were totally
destroyed now the time Jim had
disappeared it reappeared in a taking
Captain America through time and of
course I have a video about that that
you're welcome to check out if
you like to but from this point going
forward into the Marvel Universe
especially into Secret Wars in battle
world it doesn't seem as though they're
going to be infinity gems anymore it
seems as though those infinity gems are
basically gone forever at this point
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace